j'accueille maintenant
[Musique]
roxana maracineanu bonsoir
d'être championne du monde
oui vice championne olympique du 200
mètres d'où la première question
pourquoi nash sur le dos sur moi quand
genève sur le dos je me prend de l'eau
plein la gueule et je trouve ça très
désagréable parce que c'est la nage
j'étais la meilleure quand tu commences
à najib on va vous voir ma g genton man
show
[Musique]
médaille d'argent pour roxana
maracineanu
2,8 s'ajoutent sanaa marahati à nu
deuxième
des jeux olympiques c'est une france au
tchad
nhl
bravo vélo d'argent aux jeux olympiques
de sydney alors malgré ou à cause de
cette médaille d'argent
vous avez décidé de poursuivre votre
carrière jusqu'aux jeux olympiques
d'athènes en 2004 c'est sa bassine et
c'était deux premiers jeux olympiques et
puis j'ai vu un peu ce que c'était ça
m'a vraiment donné envie de revoir la
flamme dans quatre ans vous avez gagné
dans quatre ans on verra on peut pas
dire à l'avancé
c'est la première fois de ma vie que je
m'intéresse à la nage sur le dos mais
quand je vous vois je comprends pourquoi
le très joli en plus ça change du bonnet
des lunettes des bois on voit pas
tellement alors oui on voit jamais comme
ça alors vous êtes un cd à paris là
parce que vous allez faire une école de
commerce non voilà en fait tu parisienne
depuis trois semaines et j'ai repris mes
études parce que pendant deux ans je
m'étais consacrer vraiment la
préparation des jeux et là maintenant
j'ai repris mes études sur paris on va
parler de votre vie à vous aussi vous
êtes né à bucarest en roumanie en 75
vais commencer par le patinage
artistique
et puis vous avez trouvé que les profs
étaient un peu
des méthodes un peu spartiate non
surtout en gymnastique pas ce que je
ferai du patinage de la gymnastique et
puis c'est vrai que la roumanie c'est
vraiment un pays où la gym enfin on
attache beaucoup d'importance à ce sport
parce qu'ils ont une très bonne école
donc ils sont très durs aussi et
finalement comme j'avais pas tenu le
coup assez à ce moment là sur la gym je
me suis dirigé vers la natation et
finalement c'est là que j'ai eu la
meilleure chance en roumanie comment ça
se passait à l'époque seul lé talent été
repérés embrigader après ce que c'était
difficile parce que c'était comme en
allemagne de l'est où les champions elle
est championne était quand même traité
un peu comme passer c'est l'image qu'on
s'en fait ici mais c'était pas
exactement ça en fait maintenant avec le
recul je pense que c'était une chance de
faire comme ça parce que au moins ont
donné la chance à plein de gens
d'exploiter leurs talents et les
professeurs de sport qui était dans les
écoles était en même temps des
éducateurs sportifs dans des clubs et
c'est de cette manière là qu'en fait les
jeunes étaient plus diriger après vers
le sport où ils étaient les plus doués
et c'est comme ça qu'après il pouvait
faire de la compétition de haut niveau
votre père fin fin 90 début 83 votre
père vasile qu'un géant ingénieur en
génie civil en bâtiment est appelé pour
reconstruire
l'algérie enfin certains bâtiments
algérien après le tremblement de terre
il part avec son épouse avec votre mère
elena votre frère stéphane et il est
obligé de vous laisser ça c'était bien
les méthodes je m'adresse pas vous
puisque vous avez renier tout ça mais
c'était quand même le drôle de méthode
sûre que vous on vous allez garder en
roumanie
c'est une tante de ceausescu donc on
voudrait garder en roumanie vous aviez
huit ans pour avoir un moyen de pression
sur votre famille c'est ça mais il
savait très bien que les gens à partir
du moment où il était à l'extérieur du
pays il allait plutôt avoir tendance à
aller à l'étranger puisque l'on n'avait
pas la liberté de deux et les avoir
tendance à parvenir oui et donc voilà
c'est un moyen en fait pour que vous
êtes restés là bas il a fallu six mois
de tractations avant vous puissiez
rejoindre votre famille et vous
retrouvez donc en algérie et au moment
de revenir en roumanie votre père bas il
est parvenu
voilà voilà il a pris la clé des champs
on est rentré en voiture et on s'arrête
énorme dans le premier pays là vous
allez dire que je torture jean claude
gayssot mais à l'époque quand on met
quatre cantons des gens étaient prêts à
quitter parce qu'ils ont laissé de la
famille là-bas ils ont pas laissé que
c'est terrible c'était de laisser
d'autres gens mais quand les gens
étaient prêts à ça a tout quitté son
père le grand tronc romani en venant
d'algérie tda marseille qu'après les
hommes des bois paris c'est quand même
fou mais ça vous voyez bien à l'époque
quand même de nous on le voyait on nous
était pas communiste mais on voyait bien
que les gens étaient prêts à tout pour
quitter ces régimes totalitaires
c'était pas le communisme on a marché il
allait bien passer ses vacances au bord
de la mer noire et le général de gaulle
o'shea à 68 été chercher ce coup vous le
savez plus grand des visites à un chef
d'état
ce marché marché il allait en vacances
au bord de la mer noire vacances à la
mer noire tout ce qui a été fait au nom
du communisme qui consistait à interdire
qui consistait à empêcher la liberté ou
qui interdisait à des gens de circuler
de se déplacer voire d'aller vivre en
pays
tout cela est condamnable pas
condamnable à 50% et condamnable à 100%
rien à voir cependant de l'époque mois
java aujourd'hui tout le monde trouve ça
qu'on est là vous le 1er mai mme robert
hue aussi leur père lui était ainsi avec
placer quelques mois il nous a
exactement la même chose mais je voulais
je parle du temps vous travaillez avec
georges marchais et vous avez qu'est ce
qui vous a fait un du tout rien et c'est
vrai que
non mais rien n'avait pas eu de chance
de le croiser vous avez ri
non non taisez-vous ardisson n'ont
jamais ce que vous auriez pu écrire en
livret vous auriez fait fortune on bien
alors roczen a donc votre famille comme
j'aime le dire lyon paris vous dormez
alors j'ai bien vous aimez pas qu'on
vous parle de la petite immigrée qui
arrivait tout faisait quand même dormi
avec votre famille dans une voiture
pendant pendant trois semaines je serai
jamais dormi dans une voiture pendant
trois semaines c'est vrai qu'on a eu des
difficultés au départ parce que mes
parents dû tout quitter et puis laisser
tout ce qu'ils avaient comme comme
moyens d'existence en roumanie
et puis en arrivant ici y'avait pas je
veux dire on nous a pas tout donné du
jour au lendemain et puis tout ce qu'on
a eu on a dû leur on a dû la famille et
votre famille qui est restée là bas il
ya eu des gens étaient menacés ils ont
été embêté suite à la défection de vos
parents il n'y a pas eu des choses aussi
terrible comme que ce que j'ai déjà pu
voir dans des films mais c'est vrai
qu'on les a en fait on a on a un peu
empêché leur progression sociale
non là dans la société et puis dans le
voilà parce qu'ils avaient un point noir
sur leur carte comme c'est arrivé en
france que vous chose qui vous a le plus
marqué c'est les chewing gum avec
l'europe il servait c'est fou parce que
vous dites vous dites que en roumanie
avait seulement le papier d'emballage or
on laisse antennes on les mangeait pas
et on apprend qu on les regarde et les
papiers dans des cahiers ou dans des
bouquins et or est arrivé en france
évidemment des chewing gum à la
chlorophylle
il y en avait c'était assez touchant non
ouais ça mais je sais pas comment ça a
été perçu mais c'est vrai que par
exemple aux normands elle n'a pas trop
aimé que ce soit perçu comme ça parce
que ça fait un peu mais pour moi en tant
qu'enfant c'est vrai que ça m'a fait
très plaisir de voilà d'avoir des
bonbons des chewing gum des choses qu'on
n'avait pas là-bas forcément le côté
jean claude gayssot quand il dîne avec
ready votes comptés comme des
irréductibles dans votre famille votre
tente par exemple elle dit que les
une ancienne preuve d'université il ya
des gens que je veux dire sont restés
dans la mentalité de l'époque cirque
elle trouve que les gens qui gagnent de
l'argent c'est des voleurs par exemple
vous savez tout ça donc elle dit quoi
qu'elle ait jamais eu d'argent sont des
valeurs dans ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'il ya des gens dont vous vous êtes
venus ici vous êtes intégré très très
bien on le voit vous rouler plus l'air
comme elvire popesco ce qui est vraiment
génial aussi entraîné que m'a très bien
ça se voit ça a bien marché bravo mais
il ya des gens qui sont des
irréductibles sur votre tante elle
considère que les gens qui gagnent de
l'argent ce sont des voleurs il n'avait
pas l'habitude du commerce et du profit
individuel donc voilà il trouve pas ça
très très normal par rapport à ce que ce
qu'ils ont appris toute leur vie mais
elle dit des choses aussi très belle que
d'autres gens ne disent pas donc qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans le régime
ici donc en france en europe occidentale
disant qu'est-ce qui manque par rapport
à ce que vous aviez en roumanie ou à
l'éducation culture cette manière de
faire qui qui fait qu'en fait tout les
gens toutes les personnes ou les mêmes
chances un peu dans la vie à partir de
ce moment là une fois que tout le monde
ait été éduqués que ce soit au fin fond
de la campagne dans la montagne dans la
ville et c'était un plus c'est un peu
comme nous quand on regarde les états
unis par rapport à la france
on trouve qu'ils sont un peu arriérés
sur le plan social par rapport à nous
donc vous quand vous regardez la france
aujourd'hui vous pensez que par exemple
par rapport à l'éducation
il n'y a pas les mêmes chances pour tout
le monde qu'il y avait dans les pays de
l'est ya aussi les mêmes chances parce
qu'évidemment on est nous aussi ici en
france on doit il ya le col obligatoire
et tout ça mais là bas c'était un peu en
fait c'était l'école qui prime et c'est
l éducation qui primait sur la cellule
familiale
c'est à dire que toute l'éducation des
enfants étaient plutôt fait à l'école et
par l'école que les enfants étaient plus
pris en charge par l'alcool que par que
par les parents ça vous choque pas la
france d'aujourd'hui qui est livré au
libéralisme le plus le plus sauvage ça
vous gêne pas vous pensez pas qu'on
reviendra un jour à des notions de plus
de partage et de solidarité
qu'aujourd'hui attention ça me choque
pas parce que je pense qu'on est sur une
bonne voie parce que les idées
communistes et en fait c'est dans
l'application qu'elles n'ont pas marché
mais dans l'idéalisme elles sont très
bonnes et je pense pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de gens et je pense pas qu'ils
aient beaucoup de gens qui vont signé
une question de solidarité entre les
gens et d'entraidé puis penser à celui
qui est en face de vous autant que vous
pensez à vous même je crois que c'est
une bonne chose mais d'abord il faut
d'abord mettre un système économique
viable en place parce que c'est à dire
que si chacun pense à son intérêt et
puis arriva à créer des relations avec
les autres gens autour de lui on peut
arriver un truc un peu un peu jolie quoi
voilà mon nom j'ai tourné en roumanie
l'année dernière malheureusement
pourquoi malheureusement parce que ça
s'est très mal passé j'ai vécu le
tournage le plus désastreux de masi
alors que j'entends jean tendance à
jones perdait qui parle joliment de la
roumanie
mais ce que je voulais dire tout à
l'heure quand je disais c'est terrible
parce qu'on dit ça a été terrible les
années de communisme et c'est encore
terrible ce sera terrible encore pendant
50 ans en 87 vous reprenez en france la
natation 80 18 vous allez à perth en
australie
vous entendez donné championne du monde
qui souhaitait entendre la marseillaise
comme ça vous ça vous a pas pour moi
c'était vraiment le symbole une enfin
c'était ça voulait dire que j'avais
gagné et gagner les championnats du
monde non plus avant la compétition le
président de notre fédération nous a dit
qu'on n'avait jamais encore eu de
champion du monde de ça donc voilà c'est
là en fait qu'on réalise là que vous
avez réagi violemment contre la
récupération qui est fait qui a été fait
de votre exploit quand même nom quand
chirac dit quel bel exemple
d'intégration ça vous énerve un peu vous
dit après tout pour il y est pourquoi le
nom masqué ce qui m'a énervé c'est que
chacun un peu voulait récupérer des
choses qui m'étaient très personnelle
avant dont personne ne s'était occupé ou
préoccupé même si ce n'est parce qu'ils
étaient déjà en place et qui après une
fois que c'était fait chacun on voulait
enfin chacun interprété ce qui est
arrivé c'est ce manque d'intérêt mais
bon mais il ya eu des tentatives de
récupération politique on l'a bien vu
donc à l'époque jacques chirac
commercial aussi on vous a proposé de
faire un livre vous a proposé de faire
de la chanson on vous a proposé d'une
pub pour du shampoing un film de sortir
d'un gâteau d'anniversaire vous
souhaitez vous avez résisté à tout ça
mais c'était un peu traître est
différent pour moi parce que la natation
c'est pas du tout un sport qui était
médiatisée maintenant ça l'est un peu
plus et puis j'ai dû faire face à des
choses vraiment de nouvelles et j'étais
très surprise quoi par les choses qu'on
qui m'était proposé mais après certaines
choses parce qu'en fait je les fais
pendant quelques temps et je me suis
vite arrêté parce que j'ai eu assez de
gens autour de moi pour bien me recadrer
sur mes objectifs et puis je me suis
rappelé aussi que moi mon objectif ce
n'était pas ce type de champion du monde
mais c'était une participation aux jeux
olympiques
et voilà donc j'ai mis deux ans je me
suis reconcentré j'ai oublié tout ça moi
alors à sydney s'est pas aux jeux
olympiques donc vous êtes médaille
d'argent avec cette une roumaine qui a
gagné c'est pas la marseillaise que vous
avez entendu c'est donc l'hymne roumain
alors c'était c'est un peu magique c'est
vrai parce que c'est sur mes parents
étaient dans les gradins et pour eux ça
leur a fait très plaisir
moi ça m'a fait un peu moins plaisir
parce que je me suis fait battre et puis
d'autant plus que c'était une roumaine
donc c'est pas disons c'est
et c'est pas pour ça que ça être atténué
la chose puisque justement après j'ai
reçu des courriers on disait ben t'as
une médaille d'argent mais bon c'est une
roumaine c'est bien car c'est bien oui
oui mais c'est très bien je suis très
contente si je supportais pour 2004
maintenant quand vous connaît mais moi
je n'aime pas trop me faire battre donc
voila merci
alors nous faire une interview croyance
que ça m'a enlevé on ne bouge pas
pendant le dinner
[Musique]
vous avez maintenant ce qui lève le
poing comme ça c'est ceux qui sont pour
bouger par le jingle franchement alors
interview croyants soient voir en quoi
vous croyez
est ce que vous croyez que les
communistes ont vraiment changé ou que
leur profil bas et momentanée il faut
essayer peut-être j'en sais rien jean
claude gayssot très bonne idée ça
essayez la nique à venir le contraire
mais en tout cas vous pouvez faire à
natation tous les excès de vitesse que
vous voudrez je ne mangerai pas du tout
ça en natation au plus vite plus il sera
content est ce que vous croyez en vous
moi oui je crois en moi et au départ
c'est la seule chose en attendant
laquelle je croyais qu'on croyait pas en
dieu
vous y croyez ou non oui le début de la
course vous dit dieu aide moi ou non j'y
crois constamment et surtout dans les
moments
bien peu de mal alors j'y croyais pas ce
que julien clerc qu'il est un truc très
drôle il dit toute façon moi je crois
pas en dieu et quand l'avion commence à
bouger
j'y crois pas non plus quoi parce que
dans ces moments là tout le monde y
croit bien entendu vous vous y croyez
tu y croies et j'y crois un peu plus
quand je réussis à faire des choses
et chez vous quand vous étiez petit on
croyait en dieu ou c'était mal vu ou vos
parents ils croyaient pas non tout le
monde croyait en dieu on est orthodoxe
en roumanie 1 mais on n'était pas
pratiquants elle se croyait à l'effet
des crèmes antirides
j'y crois pas encore mais ça va venir je
crois vous avez dit croire aux enjeux
croyez aux anges aux enfants oui moi
c'est les enfants les anges les fantômes
que des trucs gothique un peu baroque
comme ça à vous y croyez ou pas tous ces
trucs là à les fantômes ce qu'en
roumanie tout ça en europe centrale ils
sont j'étais pas là dedans pas leur
boulot encore tard 106 américain faible
non suivant les gens qui lancent pas les
changer le
le banc ou alors ils mettaient soit de
l'or quand c'était les princes des vins
c'est bien ce soit des dubois ce tout
simplement quand c'était roturier
seulement les dépend pas de la même
façon je dise que c'est libre et finance
et j'ai touché sur le vide jamais vous
avez été sur le lit de vlad le vix devra
que la police de bacula oui bien sûr
pour aller voir ses vacances avec marché
mais j'arrête bien est ce que vous
croyez bien jacob qui va me casser la
tête à la fameuse soirée ça va être ma
fête
est ce que vous croyez à l'amour à
l'amour
ah l'amour toujours quoi l'amour
toujours voix crois mais à celui qui se
construit à vos jour le jour plus c'est
réaliste
vous croyez qu'on peut aimer sans sexe
ah oui maman platonique vous y croyez si
la fidélité vous y croyez ça c'est fait
partie du jeu du l'amour de toujours là
vous croyez à la liberté
ouais je veux y croire j'ai depuis que
je sais que je peux être libre c'est ça
que je vais essayer de faire toute ma
vie même à l'égalité à partir du moment
où on peut être libre ouais on peut être
très bon aussi le quad la fraternité
j'essaie de voir si vous êtes une vraie
française en fait mme royal et liberté à
l'égalité et la fraternité
alors je sais pas si c'est vraiment vrai
mais c'est un peu l'idéal que j'aimerais
bien y croire
[Musique]